I don't know I don't feel bad about it
you know um it doesn't affect you
emotionally no it really doesn't I mean
I've literally I've done it when I've
been sober
um I look at it like it's a job just
like you know they wake up in the
morning go to Starbucks or something you
know I see a client it's it's
uh it's an exchange you know you have
something that I want and vice versa and
you know what's wrong with that that's
how I look at it do you think
prostitution should be legalized say you
think prostitution should be legalized
do
um I I definitely
definitely like mandate not mandated but
you know like it can't be taxed you know
they can't the government can't keep up
with it you know
um kind of the same with drugs like but
I definitely think that there would be
um the highway will go down I actually
think that and I mean